right-hander mike fultonevich on the
mound for the rangers making his
second start of the season here's
machado manny hitting 242 a homer four
rbis
and fanny manny on on the stand with the
brines
and he takes strike three and eight
pitch
first inning for fulton adrian morihon
on the mound today for the padres
22 year old making his second start 64
pitch effort last time out
two for his last 16 for gallow and he'll
take ball forward that close uh two-hour
walk for
joey gallo let's see what's wrong with
morihon as
the trainer has come out along with jace
tingler
this does not look good so morihon is
going to leave this game
after a walk to joey gallo yeah not seen
anything up to that point to indicate
that he was injured in any way
yeah i'm right there with you don after
that last pitch did not notice anything
velocity seemed to be fine yes i think
so
um that was 95 i think uh on the outside
corner the delivery looked fine
so amore home leaves this game with an
injury
padres have to go to the pen craig
stamen will be given as long as he needs
to get ready with hosmer first up the
cleanup heater
fulton first pitch with a comebacker
nice job to grab it himself and throw
out hosmer one away
you throw your glove up there just in
case you might catch it this is really
good concentration
from mike bolton image he probably
wasn't hitting as hard as he thought
his glove up makes a nice play and eric
hosmer continues the streak of not
getting deep
into a bats as he puts a first pitch in
play once again
good job here by fulton grisham off to a
fast start it was four for eight in the
first two games
his first at bat today he fly it out to
right field so a second time through now
for fulton evans
and here's a drive to right field back
goes gallow
at the wall it's gone a home run trent
bush of homers again
padres jump on top one to nothing
second home run of the series end of the
season for trent grisham
it's good to have you back old glover
we just focused on the swing of trent
grisham
the one we showed you he went down and
got
there's a four seamer it's up belt
buckle high
and he gets to it nice level swing
that's a line drive folks getting out in
a hurry
texas toast on that heater the padres on
top one to nothing as we head to the
bottom of the fourth inning on the
ground right side the shift in play
and it's crowded worth who throws him
out there's four ground ball outs in a
row for craig stamet
he's got it working ties him up and
strikes him out
second strikeout for stamen second time
that solac
is down by way of the k boy talk about
burying it inside he did just that
that's about two baseballs off the plate
in
it's the two-seam fastball from stamen
runs in on him nicely one hit allowed
for stamen in this game it was an
infield hit for trevino
in the second inning he was ahead of
trevino one and two
in the fourth inning with low at first
and two down
swinging a miss and stamens able to
strike out trevino
second strikeout of the inning third
overall it's one nothing padres
and now taylor williams with the bottom
third of the batting order do up for the
rangers here in the fifth
charlie culberson to lead it off here
for the texas rangers batting out of the
seventh spot
they do not like the breaker swing and a
miss and he chases the breaker
hater flight out to centerfield in the
second inning
so i'm going to miss and almost hit him
in the back leg as he strikes out
back-to-back case
for taylor williams two down here in the
fifth well the one thing i've discovered
in this series
and if you're watching at home you're
probably witnessing the same thing that
the texas rangers really don't have any
discipline on the breaking balls thrown
by these
padres pitchers two down in the fifth
inning leyote tavares coming up here now
the
center fielder bounced out to second
base in the third inning hole for one
that is on the ground right side it's
profar who throws him out
tavares twice today has grounded to him
and a one two three fifth
for taylor williams head to the sixth
inning one-nothing padres and mike
foltenevich today
throwing the ball well 42 fastballs of
the 56 pitches that he has thrown today
grisham scoring position out there at
second
and that could be a huge run all right
another payoff to machado
got him looking machado won't let that
call
but he is the final out of the sixth
inning padres leave a man and now maybe
some momentum for the offense a breaking
ball away
and uh manny just drops the bat this
time if he's saying something to the
umpire
he's not looking over his shoulder after
getting thrown out yesterday
no runs no hits a walk one left middle
of the sixth one-nothing padres
all right well kyle cody checks in now
in the eighth inning
after an outstanding performance by
fulton just
one swing today the home run by grisham
the difference in a game that has seen a
total of five hits
ground ball up the middle sliding stop
counterfeit
and the big baby does it again nice play
to get kim well done here by isaiah
connor for left
it's not just the range but watch how
quickly he gets up
and makes the big throw he's in the
perfect position as the pitch is being
delivered and
that play wasn't even close i feel like
that one should have been close kim is
out by a few steps
well done ikf yeah nick solak coming up
now batting with one out one on here in
the eighth
swing and a miss and taking off for
second and out at second base is white
profile puts the tag on and
thrown out at second base is eli white
for out number two
they are challenging rangers will
challenge this
wow looks like he beat it first look
watch profiles need does his knee
prevent him touching the bag
kind of tough i don't know i got safe
didn't he get his hand on the bag before
the keep the glove
on oh it came off there you go see that
front hand gets there but he's off at
one point
and i think he had the tag on him then
and
he is out nicely done paul stands
26 723 disagree
base is filled with rangers two down in
the eighth padres holding on to a
one-nothing lead
jitter ronald guzman kiratini pumping
his fist
they struck him out and pagan gets out
of the gym in the eighth inning the
rangers leave them loaded
the hardest pitch of the day for emilio
pagan comes at the biggest moment no
runs
two hits two walks and they leave them
loaded go to the ninth inning last
chance to add on
jono then hosmer followed by myers
anticipated here in the ninth inning
that is driven deep and far to left
field and machado
has left the ball yard manny machado
with his second home run of the year the
padres obtain some insurance
in the top of the ninth and take a
two-nothing lead
remember it's not how you start until
you finish strikeout ground ball 63
strikeout looking
there's the ian kennedy change up middle
in
[Applause]
padres taking out a little insurance
policy here in the ninth second deck
shot yeah that's a huge home run
mark malanson the closure in here trying
to shut the door on the rangers and
sweep this series
2-2 pitch on the ground right side to
pro far
onto first and the padres sweep the
rangers
mark malanson has another one two three
ninth inning and picks up another save
as the padres behind two solo home runs